hey get out of here hey hey you piece of
[ __ ] hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to slime
rancher now in this episode I'm gonna
get a lot more [ __ ] done I need a lot
more money number one and I need to get
this wall higher before they steal all
of my chickens they eat the rooster I'm
gonna be pissed but as it stands now
they're already making babies so I
depart no you weren't rebelling before
why you're rebelling now maybe I just
gotta feed these guys you can stop being
so goddamn greedy yes I get it I guess
you don't want to be fit hurry up and
get over there anyway I'll be right back
I'm gonna get some [ __ ] gun sack of [ __ ]
you pieces of Garbo I'm gonna fire you
off into the edge of the Oblivion if you
keep [ __ ] up like this you know what
there's too many of you did you guys
reproduce or something no you do not you
do not you do not you do not why are you
going so much higher no no no no II and
in fact how do you get out you're never
getting back in that's what we do that's
how we do that is the justice that we
serve here and I will not tolerate it
anymore you guys are being fired off
into oblivion I'm sorry it's just wait
is goodbye farewell have fun in the
ocean bastards okay goodbye glad they
smile as they go off to their oblivion I
think they're hungry which is not
exactly my problem no no no no you don't
know you don't know you don't know I
don't know how you guys get [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you do not belong in my farm if
you're gonna be such [ __ ]
you [ __ ] I don't care if you're
hungry oh my god
how are you [ __ ] getting out of this
you know what this is [ __ ] how the
Frick [ __ ] are you how I don't
understand how you guys got in there
what in the [ __ ] happened
okay anyway we're gonna pretend like
that isn't reality and we're just gonna
have a good old time here while I fire
these [ __ ] off into the yes oh you
want to survive no oh no I tried to save
you and now you're dead okay I can get
more of you you're replaceable man all
my chickens at least I didn't get my
roosters but it's just one hand to these
two roosters
they even got my stony ones dammit oh
they're fighting Oh No call it white no
it's norm so that is that I'll be right
back I gotta deal with this [ __ ]
what is this treasure pot is locked okay
I didn't even know what a treasure pot
was I don't know why it's locked
oh you are you well that was horrifying
oh you jump big good okay well this is
just sad I'm gonna get out of here yeah
all righty then wow those guys are
unhappy why are they out in the middle
of the day that doesn't make any sense
gold gold oh come on do I feed it do I
have two feet I thought I have to poo uh
I just blasted goddamnit the gold mother
humper all right let me go in here and
see if I can remember if I can get these
guys to calm down and nobody's cube Oh
ooh okay all right whoa whoa whoa whoa I
got food for you buddy they're so happy
now whoa hi friend
boink okay sorry about that
they're happier now we're angry no no no
no no no ow
what the hell no eat that ah oh no not
you oh jeez explosions are awfully steel
what are the secrets you hiding from me
where does this go oh it's a lock - I
wish oh maybe maybe that key might be
from the pink one and then the other one
is from the Catwoman and then I can
figure out which one to go to later mmm
secret secrets we're getting to the
bottom of this but I'm not back yet so
everybody go away ow ow ow stop it
point point point Oh Oh it was just one
more okay I got a key I got a key boink
yay yes nurse whatever this currency is
is it in Europe's I think it's yours
not Arab Center but I might be nervous
all right whatever anyway gonna take my
fruit and run let me see if this key let
me see if it goes to this ash product on
my floors back I'm gonna dump my flirts
back up I'm not back yet ever everybody
go away
I'm not here you didn't see nothing I'm
an enigma market baller doesn't exist
markiplier never was
there's no channel here what are you
talking about Zhaan illusion I'm a paid
actor okay that's a good amount of money
maybe I can get an upgrade now for
myself
water tank store fresh water jet pack or
module the water tank that's how it get
water all of these are good but I like
the jet pack I do want the jet pack i
like'em me a jet pack and then maybe
forget what the end of grade high walls
350 okay so I'm close to getting high
walls for these bad boys you go on some
more head hands there you go okay now
I'm officially back let's see if this
cave actually has the key
oh no if I have the key to this caves
door hey everybody who's so happy about
that I love the art of that that was
Heys so what's going on in here Oh
indigo quarry all the remains of a wall
wall the remains of a mining project
right they quickly went bust okay
I was always happiest when I was told by
my lonesome places like this old quality
really suited me nice and quiet and
mostly empty so I figured that life on
the far far range would suit me just as
well and well wouldn't you just know it
I come all this way and the first person
I see well she changed how I saw things
quiet wasn't good anymore
I'd like to laugh oh that's so nice yes
real nice okay so what do I do about
this quarry is there like some special
poopie here oh we got oh we got an
assortment whoo we got a whole plethora
Bryant pink boom Largo here have one of
these give me your book
give me your boom Boop oh that's nice
boom Boop okay I'm gonna take that don't
boo me eat that oh [ __ ] you're a little
concerned to be oh wow alright that guy
eat that eat it Oh Benji and me eat eat
give give give give me your quartz I
want hey oh god I'm gonna die
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I just want your ports
just try to scoop up the remains of
whatever floor sir oh boy oh this is a
bad time to come over here oh this was
not ideal not ideal they are all dying
very quickly Oh should I go deeper oh
that I saved him oh boy
ah [ __ ] well can't save nobody no more
oh boy okay I just sacrifice the rock
Lord I'm sorry I saw online oh hey
you're in here eh
oh well that's nice treasure pods are
locked I don't know where I went I ran
away from the guitars what's going on
here oh wow oh that's cool
neato burrito man this place is so much
bigger than I thought it was they've
expanded in a big way around all of this
island and this is like a lot more to
see Oh what are you are you radiation
slimes are you wanting you want to eat
these hens is that what you want what do
you eat rad slimy
wheat veggies I don't have veggies on me
oh you are rad slimes you're so rad
give me those [ __ ] nope oh damn it I
don't write whatever that didn't work
out well but okay don't eat don't eat
don't eat I don't eat that plug don't
eat that part I get it
oh god I got radiation on me yeesh
getting deadly here puddle Blore it's a
puddle corn this is more slimes in there
oh that's cool
oh that's really cool oh hello more plot
I used to come here when I needed a good
soak it's a great way to clear your head
sometimes I'd catch a puddle slime
blushing and I could never tell if it
was because I was in my bathing suit or
[Music]
flirting with slimes that's weird and
what do we got here
whoa oh my God look at that are those
flowers oh there's so many of you where
am i oh I'm in the deepest part of this
cave that's neat oh that's neat a read
Oh see where this goes
may not go anywhere but I don't know
okay you owe nothing apparently they're
ash flowers it's burst into ass before I
could get to him oh that one's so pretty
oh that one's like a special different
version of it know that it's a crystal
slime whoa okay there that's awesome
that's so cool there's another treasure
pot over here but I don't know how to
open them Oh God oh oh oh okay I'm out
of here I see that other text there but
I'll come get it later
when I'm actually need to be here
gathering up some slimes and actually
building pens for them
I could try to take a rad slime home but
I don't think it's gonna be useful you
upgrade available okay so I get better
sprinting it's not bad Oh the end mother
lode a but I'm full right you hands I'll
come back for you you stay good okay but
that's cool so that's a whole nother
segment with even more slimes that could
possibly be for who knows how many uses
hey big buddy I'll come back for you
later I don't have enough veggies right
now but I'll come back though you worry
where am I going oh I'm still oh I
didn't even realize I was still in the
crystal land a whelp that's bad
just gonna pretend like nothing's
happening and ignore that I don't have
nothing I can do about it so we're
really worried you remember me I still
still exploit oh you can you can still
took a wolf it's not exploit apparently
for you oh god what's with these
treasure pots do you guys know what the
treasure pods are about because there's
treasure pods here and I want to know I
want to open them I want to open them
somehow but I don't know whatever I'll
get to it later figure it out okay here
we go let's load it up oh my god
Rockport's oh the rock oh no those are
crystals oh okay the rad ports are good
oh the boom ports are good oh I got so
much stuff okay I can finally start
housing you [ __ ] again but maybe I
should just spend my money on a better
pen I know I can get I can get a good
one as long as I got high walls should
be fine either way high walls probably
good and then an auto feeder would be
good but I don't have the money for that
right now so oh my god right now or that
so anyway I'm gonna I'll be back I'm not
done yet I'm not done yet I got more to
do and maybe I should take a little nap
Inu let's see Beatrix is 4 okay whatever
all right go sleep till morning get a
good night's sleep
I sleep with a slime plushie oh that's
so self-serving all right so we got high
walls in that pen we might as well put
something good in that one like a rat if
I get a radiation one in there that's
gonna be good for me ooh maybe I could
you try to get the volcano ports Oh boom
slime boom baby boom baby okay so if I
get enough boom slimes
oh damn it always always always you
surprised me with that with your thorny
[ __ ] right but if I get more of these
boom boys and that could spell good news
for me and bad news for all of my
competitor slime Ranchers
cuz I'm gonna make more money film man
put them out of business
that's how this works right it's another
one of those guys I don't know what to
do about the golden one I wish I knew
what to do about the golden one I wish
oh god freak you go away I don't like
you how about I give him a fruit of some
sort and okay oka where'd he go
eyes gone what do you do about the
golden ones I think the only thing you
could do is just feed him right or maybe
I'm not good enough to be able to farm
him up okay how did I get back to the
volcano area I think was over here maybe
goddammit I forgot my jet pack wasn't
recharged frickin dick well that sucked
ass well that was all pointless because
now my boom slimes are gone gray [ __ ]
grey one all of you well I want the
crystal pork oh okay got it
I'm gonna give these crystal slimes
whistle slimes whistle slimes my babies
whoo okay don't be shy supports yes yes
ow
no yes oh you were about to poop well
oops
my babe I got Krystal Floyd's now that's
good Oh
seems like a dangerous place to be but
just want to get me some ports just want
to get me some boards just want that
okay he's buried in there amongst
friends no not you eaten up all the plot
the valuable ports incredibly valuable
parts Oh Pam Jesus slamming okay you
come here you blam
you're good whoa Oh this is death no
don't get knocked out oh my god I'm out
of here Frank I'm out I'm out I'm out II
I'm calling I'm calling it I'm calling
it quits I'm calling it quits while I'm
ahead
I'm gonna take these very valuable
things back home with me before I did
[ __ ] no don't go did well thing is I
don't know if I want all of these
crystal bad boys inside of this Oh
hearing did this I once came here to
collect crystals for a little project -
mine was trapped here for nearly two
days when those curious crystal slimes
came rolling my way and started firing
all those dangerous odds I thought it
was gonna kick the pocket the crystals
worth for a wind chime I bet Thoris
still has it hanging from the porch with
it oh how romantic you almost died love
hey that's enough crystal slime stop
sprinting please recharge pleased I'm
not gonna get caught with my pants down
again all right so we got some money we
got a lot of valuables and we got even
better we are crystal slime so I'm
pretty sure these crystal slimes are
gonna be worth a whole heck in lot to me
because just their ports are like I
think 40 apiece they're a big value in
and the boom slimes are good but you
know at least the crystal ones don't
explode whenever that kill near home so
these might be better to keep alive and
then I can just I can just focus on
sustaining these bad boys I don't worry
about anything else oh hey
oh no no okay so the question is I don't
know if crystal slimes need a special
container because the crystal slimes
were in a cave system so it may be that
the crystals lives needs the cave area
to thrive in so hopefully I can get
enough money to be able to open up I may
not have enough cuz I'm pretty sure
maybe it's the foss for once or maybe
the crystal ones need like the solar net
or the Solar protector cuz that might be
a - because I think this is gonna be
like a thousand oh it's forever okay so
I can't do that but what I can do maybe
is create a solar protection like Solar
shield because if I had to imagine it's
probably the Solar shield that's gonna
help these guys right yeah always happy
oh look at them alright see you guys are
there so just imagine that you guys get
a regular sustainable supply of carrots
and you're super happy and you give me
more crystals give me those crystals yes
oh my god that's that's Kiwi that's so
scary is that you having fun that your
version of fun you guys look like you're
having so much fun I'm just gonna leave
these here for you so I don't have an
auto feeder right now but that's the
best that I can do tell you both reasons
I bet alrighty then
you guys stay in there you're having a
good time I'm not gonna put all of them
in there just yet I'm gonna see if these
guys these guys okay here cuz I got meat
for them
I got meat oh we got a lots of meat for
you guys you guys want some boom-boom
meat yeah you do I leave these guys in
there with you to stop play nice I
suppose are you boom boom boys
boom boom boys and boom boom girls boink
boink boink and a Boing Boing Boing boy
okay we're doing a lot better than we
did at the beginning of this episode
that's for goddamn sure and if I get
enough grade I can get the - boots
Oh more efficient hell yeah and then the
Power Core would be good ah yeah more
energy that's definitely going to good
and then the tank booster all getting
next so I can carry more stuff back and
forth oh they're so happy look how happy
they are I could put the rest of the
slimes in there but I don't want to go
overboard or else I'm just gonna die so
that is it for this episode thank you
everybody so much for watching I love
just like the pleasantness of this game
it's just really really like nice right
shell these show them so I'll try to
feed them I guess you guys don't eat
yeah none of these guys eat fruit so I
probably got to replace that with more
veggies but we'll get that we'll cross
that bridge when we get to it so either
way thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
in the comments below
that guy's trying to make an escape with
his bloom powers not today and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]